ladies and gentlemen
the all-time leading scorer you have
witnessed it
LeBron James
uh I just want to say um you know thank
you to the Laker faithful um you guys
are one of a kind
um
to be able to be in the presence of such
a legend and great as Kareem it means so
much to me it's very humbling
um please give a standing ovation to the
to the captain please
um
to my beautiful wife my daughter my two
boys my friends my boys my family my
mother all my man everybody that's ever
been a part of this run with me the last
20 years 20 plus years I just want to
say I thank you so much because I
wouldn't be me without y'all all y'all
help all your passion all y'all
sacrifices help me get to this point
and to the NBA to Adam Silver to the
late great David Sterner I thank you
guys so much for allowing me to be a
part of something I've always dreamed
about and um I would never ever in a
million years uh drink this even better
than what it is tonight so
[__] man thank you guys
oh what a moment
February 7
2023 the kid from Akron Stan has made
NBA history in downtown Los Angeles
just a phenomenal achievement and to put
it in perspective of how great his
career has been there's only seven NBA
players now within 10
000 points of LeBron James one of them
being our own Shaquille O'Neal
passing of the torch
from 1984 to 2023 from one liquor to
another Kareem to LeBron
from Wilt to Kareem to LeBron in those
Laker uniforms
LeBron James
the NBA's all-time scoring record holder
[Music]